how did my life find me in this
situation
the lung full of cinnamon and a condom
led Jesus hello Internet hello Internet
we once put a Johnny on his head and he
inflated it with the power of his nose
it looked like this quality now we're
gonna do it the same again we'll be able
to fill it with water
Bonnie can I choose the flavor yeah go
for vanilla nice it's better than banana
okay okay you go over the front level of
you under all over the back okay
let's up like a medical procedure start
the front
I don't thing start the front of yet huh
yeah yeah she's over yeah oh is it broke
all right let me frame up let's Bigelow
oh holy God and your little bobble
alright let's get under this summer
alright Johnny you know that's that one
side that you want to use the bat nozzle
or is it best to you
alright sound out there oh it's just
gonna be diabolical royal there's a bit
higher up I do that laughing oh don't
get bitter water in there try and make
it get ready yeah get there
get out there get out there get it up
there this is awful oh this one I read
two things I've ever done
lookie lookie buddy alien from Doctor
Who Oh God you got hose right up into
the tip of your Johnny my head Johnny
can you see uh not really
I could see you I could see it all right
hold still hold still I'm gonna go turn
on the war yeah hold the King holding
the kick hold of the king
oh not good ah ah piano all right don't
let go yeah a lot let go
it's just dribbling in
alright let's go do it
it's just good huh oh great okay great
I'll see what we got
oh well I can come from oh that there we
go this is it this is it oh oh no no pop
it look up breathe you breathe it's
working it's working
you're not fishballs the last hey scary
experience
hmm your trap you're drowning in a
fishbowl
hmm well that and the cinnamon one were
definitely my least favorite videos to
film yeah ever yeah
I had fun with that one oh I'm sure you
did you were pissing yourself at the
back there so you lose one point you
were like I can't breathe then you stood
up and I wasn't sit down like Oh bleep
oh I see a little bit it wasn't pissing
I'm here like oh well thanks for
watching and uh I'm glad that finally
what we have to do that again no no we
don't see in the next one seems a Negro
she can free Twitter I'm gonna go change